[Musik]
hollywood wasser feuer deine erste
klappe meine erste klappe ja manch nicht
berühmt weil sie schafft es ja wenn ich
du wär dann oder ja aber ehrlich helene
fischer ist auch geschafft oder sowieso
so ist es und jetzt auch geschafft dann
ist für dich kein problem oder herz ich
weiß nicht was ich mache aber es wird
genial - also jetzt mal fünf minuten
zeit nicht länger und wir machen
eigentlich ein ganz normales racing und
der hallo liebe zuschauer ich bin der
moral
ich mache ein hieß gesunde ist aber es
schmeckt und wie gesagt ich mache jetzt
mal ganz einfaches rezept was jedermann
bei einem nachmachen kann wenn die
frauen zu hause ist das lachen du
eigentlich okay wir sind glücklich okay
das ist ganz wichtig hier mache ich nur
erst in so eine schale rein weil wenn
ein schlecht ist dann ist es egal
so das war das sind auf jeden fall
glücklicher das heißt die sind die
bio-eier ist etwas teurer
wo hast du dir her ja vom biohof ja die
haben die fühler mir persönlich
vorbeigebracht so glück nicht wann liegt
es soll jetzt habe ich hier sechs eier
reingemacht jetzt nämlich
ok die panik war der erste das besondere
ist die eier wirklich sehr gut zusammen
zu schlagen denn wir schlagen das ist
eigentlich egal wo man zuschlägt ob das
schreiben echt egal ob rechts oder links
und dreht das ist völlig egal
dann nehmen wir diese eier hier ist
wieder fünf minuten
nehmen sie sich einen job ist eine
türkische knoblauch möchte ich mich
wirklich toll und tobin gefallen ist
keine produktplatzierung ich bin kommen
hat er nix die schmeckt wirklich klasse
hier wird eben deutschland übrigens
hergestellt die wurst aus ging es aber
auch in der türkei aber die würste
türkei muss er ist nicht schmecken nicht
so gut jetzt nicht mal unsere und
gegessen damals der türkei und was wir
damit sagen wollte ist kann man den
special effekt macht jetzt noch mal
unser hund gegessen und diese wäsche
computermarkt park stoffe also aus
gingen schnell ich hab nur noch drei
minuten
nehmen sie ab egal wer es ist auch wenn
es finanzamt ist dann mache ich das
natürlich anders es ist toll aus und so
einfach so ich gehe hier auf stufe fünf
langsam hoch heizen ich ja auf 4
die braucht kein fett 3 machen weil da
ist genug fällt wenn ihr merkt dass ein
auto ungesunde sachen drin ist mir aber
egal das schmeckt mir einfach so und
jetzt tue ich die hoch heizen wir haben
das wieder fünf lasse mir geben gleich
hoch auf boost das darf normalerweise
nicht bei so einer hat bei seiner ring
bei seiner reisen planen beide könnten
sich verbiegen
ich mache schon macht schon jetzt
brauche ich schon genau das brauche ich
hier das hat was ist das nochmal
anwender anwender so es gibt ziemlich
langsam
induktion geht normalerweise ziemlich
schnell genauso schnell gas warum
ach gott und die stadt die ganze zeit
war falsch erkannt
aber du kannst einfach nicht die mittel
das bringe nicht so durcheinander
ok dann habe ich noch die solchen
einzelnen sekunden ein machen so ist ja
da hat uns die technik natürlich wieder
ein schnippchen geschlagen
auf jeden fall schön anbraten lassen
merkt kann nicht beim ersten mal
vielleicht welches zwei meter länge
haben das war ja ich muss mir erst mal
an die küche gewöhnt damit nicht so auch
in der küche karriere macht ja welche
ihn noch nicht in der küche auskennen
also das ist schon richtig knoblauch ich
dann heute noch eine prise salz bei euch
sieht es immer so viel aus ich gar nicht
hier
doch das war zu viel
aber mal weiter so ihr merkt schon
richtig cool anbraten macht es mit einem
deckel welt ist riecht dann ziemlich
penetrant
und wenn die pfanne heiß genug ist
richtig also jetzt einfach schön drin
lassen und warten bis bis bis es richtig
angebraten nicht will dann können die
eier ganz normal wänden also richtig
jetzt keine fehler machen hier um zu
wursteln oder so jetzt ja auch gut an um
zu verstehen und dann ist er trägt jetzt
warte mal kurz jetzt können auch die
stufe runter stellen auf 7
da gibt es den kleinen trick und zwar
machen wir jetzt ein bisschen hoch da
kann man das ist doch guten reinlaufen
das war wahnsinn wahnsinn wahnsinn was
ich dir sagen braucht von mir kann ja
nicht von mir kommen können
also wie gesagt ihr seht fertig
wahnsinnig ist das erste rezept und
steigerung natürlich den steinbruch und
das nächste mal mache ich es ja habe ich
erstmal die basics und genau das ist
erstmal basic genau mitmachen einiges
geschafft das ist ein typisches gericht
dass wir jeden sonntag essen oder auch
jeden samstag oder freitag mit wenn man
wohnt aber nur wenn wir keine freunde
treffen damit ja so ist es damit
probieren wir probieren das kann schon
mal so eine ecke raus schon besorgt mal
so und so
sally
jemand schatz danke wie die proben sind
aus wenn ich hoffe es mundet rapper
schmeckt wirklich wahnsinn oder
danke fürs frühstück bei mir sagen guten
appetit und also uns nächste mal mache
ich dann nochmal wahnsinnige sagt ich
weiß nicht was ich mache aber sie werden
genial sein
der zuschauer wenn sie aus menschen
wünschen euch was ich mache mich alles
nicht kann auch backen
ja ich weiß nicht was ich machen aber es
wird genial also sowie gesamtmarkt gut
auf wiedersehen
[Musik]